tonight is the night ladies and
gentlemen you know i'm sitting here and
i'm thinking it's a really slow news day
and it is but there but there is
something that's happening that will
make today
the biggest news day and that is
whether or not liz cheney wins or loses
her primary in the polls
she suspect she's expected to to lose
handily but i'm not here to say one way
or another because we really don't know
speculation that democrats are going to
jump to the republican party so they can
vote for her to sabotage the republicans
because they know republicans ain't
going to vote for her in the general
maybe
or maybe we will uh see
the end of the cheney family reign and
uh this this will have a huge impact you
know moving forward with republicans
should they win in the midterms in
november in the general
what that means for donald trump what
that means for the for investigation so
we'll get into all that stuff we got a
couple other really big stories
the fbi
reportedly stopped a bunch of
traffickers and rescued a bunch of kids
a lot of people on on social media are
saying two things one well that's really
good thank you very much fbi and two
they really needed a win right now so
maybe they cleverly timed this one
so we'll get into that plus uh we'll
talk about a bunch of other weird stuff
too we've got while we're waiting for
the results to come in and and we'll see
if they come in um
you know i suppose early enough for us
to get them and then and then talk about
it but we're talking a lot about what's
going on with the republican party with
liz cheney with kinzinger and alaska is
also having their primary and then we've
got some other stories too we'll talk
about the line city you may have heard
about this saturday building this big
linear city very weird and tesla's
optimus robot oh before we get started
head over to timcast.com
and become members if you'd like to
support our work and you'll get access
to the tim cast irl uncensored after
hours show and let me just stress that
last night's show was probably one of
the spiciest and it was so spicy i was
like i don't know if we can put this one
up on itunes because we usually put one
of the members only on itunes on sunday
for the uncensored show but this one's
about a dog
that got monkey pox
and i'm gonna leave it there for the
sake of being family friendly uh how did
the dog get monkey pox mystery and where
was the monkey box located
anyway we just launched the uh promo
episode for cast castle which jack
posobik is in
and there's a really really funny bit so
you want to check that one out and well
that's not a bit it's real so it's real
totally totally green
absolutely that's right well we had to
say that for this group too yeah yeah
that's right oh yes so smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and of course
jack bosobic is here you know when um
when you said uh tonight is the night i
thought you were about to say tonight is
the night when two become one
yeah from spice girls
not up on the spices really sorry really
nobody no
chad chad help me up on this one help me
out on this one ginger spicy but guys no
um tim i do have to apologize because i
brought a hate symbol oh don't you you
can't show that no i can't no i'm going
well i'm sorry
he's taking off youtube i'm doing it so
i'm doing i got my hate symbol right
here oh my god right here
belt fed prayers directly into the face
of the demonic goodness just just just
boom boom boom
we can even get cruise we can get crew
served up this is right this is a rugged
rosary it's by rugged rosaries um
douglas ernst just just just for because
you set this up a lot of people don't
know yeah context
uh oh yeah couple outlets well what
context it's a rosary they said rosaries
are have been co-operative atlantic it
was the atlantic yeah they said rosaries
were copted by extremists
apparently um that's that's that's a new
one to me i mean we actually do funny
like i mean not funny enough but i mean
uh we do the rosary every day with in my
family i do with my boys um that's just
we went over to poland we're saying the
rosary over in this uh this basilica
that's near my family's
um village we're from sobi family you
know village back home so it's yeah it's
definitely so i admit it oh yeah
put it this way if if that group of
if you're living in a degenerate society
that's controlled by people like that
and they call you an extremist then i
say yes absolutely well we should
definitely talk about this because this
is it's just so crazy and uh well thanks
for for coming jack we also have derek
harvey hey good to be here tim and good
to be with my good friend jack and uh
it's been a fun time this summer
and looking forward to some good things
coming up is is that pillow story true
so okay do you know tim i mentioned this
before him but i don't think ian was in
the room so i might have to bring this
up ian do you know about
the the backstory between me and derrick
no i'm gonna need to know though okay so
four four years ago and you can see
what's on the shelf right behind me and
the alpaca has been put to sleep that's
true by the by the travel size my pillow
but believe it or not and derek you can
back me up on this
he was the first person to ever give me
my first my pillow
100 true 100 it's true it's true right i
forgot all about that yeah
let's not read too much into that well
no it was oh your wife got a force
actually but in all seriousness so
complimentary pillow
we purchased a few extra ones and and uh
jack had said some things and we thought
oh well he he said he had a bad neck or
something at the time i did not say i
had a bad knee what are you talking
about
bad neck what's this
i'm just imagining i'll have that script
slowly being handed to jack and his eyes
are glowing like sparkling he's like so
we gave it to you
or something didn't we use the picnic
yeah yeah and then you got a taste of
the comfort
and i i got like
i was i i've never looked back and now i
see i see pillows that are just
sub-standard everywhere i go we have to
do this for cast castle yes the scene as
soon as you touch the pillow it like the
camera zooms into your eyes and you see
like eternity the truth exactly pictures
him like laying on a pillow floating
around what's that what's that thing all
the secrets of the universe what's that
thing from adult swim he's like i've
seen beyond the find the star i don't
know just like course he was actually
wondering what the heck is derek giving
me
yeah well they come in the pillows they
come in like a it's it's it's um it's
too bright it's it's sealed and so it's
and it's pressure wrapped so when you
get it it's actually kind of rolled this
is not a commercial no it's not this is
like actually a story no there's
actually a story right so they're
they're rolled and i was like what the
heck why was my pillow rolled and then
he said well he said the thing about the
dryers you have to throw it in the dryer
for like one spin and then i was like
all right fine whatever i definitely
left it in the bag for like six months
and then didn't even think about it and
then finally we i just said i'm gonna
give this a shot better not now it's not
imagining jack gets the pillow and
doesn't care and then it's like six
months later goes into his basement and
he what's this and he picks it up and
it's glowing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway anyway we'll we'll we'll we'll
talk more derek thanks for being the
rest is history but it was it was derek
it was not mike lindell
you worked with devin nunes you've been
on the show before and i think you
recently won a primary yeah i did in
washington county for county
commissioner republican primary and now
it's up against the democrats in the
fall right on it's awesome
yeah dude what's county commissioner
consist of well we have oversight of a
lot of programs in the county
school budget
roads
highways
sewer and water
zoning
just a lot of sheriff's department law
enforcement that's great about an 800
million dollar a year budget and
you know we're trying to protect the
history and values and character of the
county it's a great place to live and we
like to keep it that way not become
louden county
yes all right we got lydia pressing
buttons i am pushing buttons in the
corner delighted to have these two
gentlemen this great minds trust i'm
stoked for the pillow the alpaca is
sleeping on we're going to be going on
the news let's jump to the first story
from cnn
liz cheney faces referendum on her trump
criticism
just that in tough wyoming primary you
know i don't need to say too much based
on the story this is just the lead story
harriet hageman is pulling way higher
and everybody expects liz cheney to be
soundly defeated and i'm seeing a lot of
criticism because what are they calling
her a carpetbagger is that it's you know
she's not from there she doesn't know
the community yeah she comes from
somewhere else and then what she does is
she wyoming is th this is why
i'll tell you i think she's gonna lose a
lot of people do
i don't wanna jinx it i don't know who
knows what happens with democrat
crossover or whatever but wyoming is
maga country quite literally the number
one most trump supporting state in the
union yes and liz cheney is the number
one tds
trump derangement syndrome politician i
don't understand what she thinks is
happening and why she didn't just retire
like kenzinger did
i almost feel like it's a pride thing at
this point you know it's you know this
is our party
and we want you you know and keep in
mind she thinks she's right right she
thinks she's wait she's riding some wave
of something that over time that the
establishment will still be able to win
so the establishment can come back
defeat all of mega tell all the
deplorables to shut up um that she'll be
able to go she's all in right she's all
in and whether that includes a
presidential campaign in 24 which oh god
i hope she runs please please liz
please run in 24 please i'd love to see
her on a primary stage
i mean come on right talk about a steel
cage match
that this would be i mean it'd just be
the ratings would be
gold you could buy the whole government
but so the the idea though is that with
her dying she comes from political
royalty right this was this is the karl
rove george they're sort of like the
offshoot of the george bush dynasty so
you can't
you can't talk about the cheneys without
talking about the bushes and that was
the previous ruling class the ruling
family of the republican party she's
like republican hillary clinton yeah
yeah you know it's like she's like no i
don't want to lose i refuse me
but a lot of people miss that you know
in in those 2016 primaries when people
said oh it's going to be so hard for for
trump to beat the clintons their dynasty
etc everybody forgets that he took out
jeb bush very quickly yeah very very
quickly come on jeb he put an
explanation because that's how it was
that's how it used to be though it used
to be that you could have you could be a
politician and you could represent
wyoming and then do absolutely nothing
for your state and it was a do nothing i
mean the fact that dick cheney and liz
cheney were both representing wyoming
name one thing they've actually done for
their state ever right nothing nothing
please collapse they have good crypto
laws does that have anything to do with
them no not governor
yeah i'm a big advocate of not hating
the child for the sins of the father no
no she's certain
that's neither am i in which case so we
could talk about what she's done yeah
well dick cheney for instance was vice
president of george w bush i feel like
he was a big part of why we got into the
war in the middle east i don't know if
i'm right or wrong about it just a
little bit no more derek i mean you were
kind of present for it well i worked
with dick cheney during the first gulf
war when he was secretary of defense and
i worked with him off and on in 2003 to
2006 and i stayed in touch with him over
the next decade
um
definitely a
you know a neocon
aggressive
war hawk if you want to want to call it
that but liz cheney is
cut from the same mold and neither one
of them focuses on the real threat to
america which seems to be right here at
home with the weaponization of doj and
fbi and the threats against our civil
liberties and what china is doing
domestically there they don't seem to
care
they're like looking outward for the
problem i'll work for the problem and
they're part of the establishment and in
their bubble they don't understand
what's going on in america they're not
part of real america
it has always eluded me how exactly liz
cheney got to be the representative for
wyoming
i was like well surely she's like
representing vermont or something well
that's where the family's from
originally yeah yeah that makes sense
but i was like she in no way represents
anything that's going on in wyoming she
has no she's not on anything
that's what i'm trying to say though
that's how prior to 2016 that's how
politics was yeah if you were the big
name from a certain state
and you could pay enough money to be on
tv that was pretty much it well that's
why you would win that's why jeb thought
he could one win by being jeb yeah and
that's not the case i think jeb and also
hillary really great examples of this
older generation completely unaware of
what the internet was no seriously yeah
hillary clinton
went to where was she like in alabama
and she put on a southern drawl like
dude people know what you sound like you
can't do this but
she just didn't realize jeb please clap
he didn't realize people were going to
film that put on the internet
absolutely i went to jeb's uh opening
campaign uh announcement and gala in
florida my wife and i attended and
it was
really shocking for him to come down and
talk to everyone and lay out his vision
and he came out attacking the base
attacking the principles and values that
reflected the average republican voter
talking about immigration and we need to
love all these immigrants we have room
for them we need to embrace them
when we were having massive problems
along the border
well donald trump said what did he say
let him all come legally
legally
and he's right that basically means well
obviously you're not going to let 100
million people in your country overnight
they're all going to line up you're
going to say fill out the form and let's
figure out how we can help you and and
what we can do and if we can handle the
the the capacity make sure we're we're
helping people come here and thrive
instead what we end up with biden is
basically a de facto open border where
people are dying in the deserts and and
it was bad under trump it was um
the the apprehensions were really really
high but this is what people need to
understand
under donald trump the um was it
apprehensions and what do they call it
um
what's the what's the word they use
for when an ice agent confronts ways no
no they can encounter
yeah i knew it was like something weird
we're like what does that really mean
but uh you have to understand under
trump it went it went way up and
everyone's like oh look it's it's worse
now it's like no no this is what
enforcement looks like good yeah when
trump started enforcing this
you saw encounters increase which means
under obama they were ignoring it even
worse now you got hey i'll give the guy
credit joe biden actually wants to build
the wall out in arizona they want it
they want to cover some gaps in yuma
well did you see that thing on
postmoneel today with savannah hernandez
no she's got a whistleblower from
one of the federal contractors that's
doing these these night flights
and this guy comes for totally anonymous
and they've got the receipts on it where
he's saying that oh yeah do we have kids
he goes
my office alone does two thousand to
five thousand kids per week that they're
flying around the country and that's out
and there's four of these offices
through across the border that's crazy
man and
and all of it they're just flying and
it's federally contracted and the sort
you know the they're they're we're told
that they have sponsors right and they
don't even know the vetting of the
sponsors the whole chain is broke it's
just too many people right it's too many
people we don't even have the actual
abilities and derek you know it's better
than me um we don't even have the
correct functions of government to be
able to process that many people let
alone that many minors
there was that that viral video that got
leaked where uh
it was one of these guys working on
these flights who said if the american
people knew what their government was
doing
you know there'd be like a revolt
overnight or something like that you
remember that it was it was uh up in new
york i think yeah that was new york they
were trafficking kids
let me just stress it it's been reported
several times the biden administration
is trafficking children this is it's
crazy and the big story broke when the
the trafficking was secretly filmed they
were bringing kids uh illegal immigrant
children into tennessee i think it was
was that what it was the tennessee
tennessee gop found out they were super
pissed off a bunch of other videos came
out like the one in new york where
you've got these contractors being like
yup
working for the government trafficking
children but when they get into a place
like knoxville tennessee or some other
city it's churches
and
left-leaning democratic organizations
that are funded by the government that
pose as
ngos non-government entities are
supposed to be doing these good works
and they're making profits and it's a
business and the more of it the better
and it's changing the demographics and
you know you got to follow the money and
it's a it's a
self-looking ice cream cone going on
here yeah so people are making money off
of off of bringing kids to churches is
that what you're saying
to towns the people are offloaded they
get funded by the government the state
and federal government there's a ton of
federal money in this ton of federal
money and
people are employed and they take care
of them and they manage these people and
they help them with the transition and
it's a profession what what i just it
just liz cheney really is astounding to
me that she
she's she didn't look
tons of these uh
established republicans retired and
they've been retiring like crazy
realizing
it's it's over there's a there's a
there's a maga wave of republicans who
care about this country that are
starting to come in that want to see
real change i see the left making fun of
marjorie taylor green she says defund
the fbi and i'm like don't you agree
with her on that point like you can make
fun of her i guess but at least you can
say that you agree with her on that
point they should be happy about the
changes that are happening at least to a
certain degree so to see liz cheney i
suppose you put it you know uh right you
put it you stated it correctly that
she's refusing to let go it's her party
she's like one of the last
barnacles latched onto the holes the
ship's leaving and she refuses to give
up but i'm just getting to this because
while immigration is one of the most
important issues for for for americans
and there's a constant news story about
the crisis
kids are dying in the desert what is she
doing donald trump said mean things
is that it is that what you know or well
not only that but she she's the head uh
essentially the republican head of the
january 6th committee yeah she's the one
and she's basically the one running it
but there's no meaningful investigation
you know where where are the text
messages where is that where are the
reports what was going on with that pipe
bomb what was going on with why are
there people in the crowd that we didn't
have to rehash everything what was nancy
pelosi doing what was pelosi up to why
didn't they use the pac public address
system on the on the capitol grounds so
many of these just if you were
conducting an actual investigation that
you would want the answers to because of
course she doesn't want that she's made
this the face of her last hurrah she
wants to go down with the ship and then
this is playing to the msnbc cnn base of
people who are out there those suburban
wine moms and
you know you're you're like uh
it's the soccer mom like the soccer moms
in in masks and you know get your third
booster get your fourth booster did you
see the next latest uh liz cheney
how how long
after she loses assuming she does until
she gets a cnn or msnbc contributor [ __ ]
it's already set up i'm sure they're
fighting over they're probably fighting
over her right now um now if she's smart
by the way and it depends on how you how
you run the money on this what she would
do is you do the liz cheney foundation
so she does the liz cheney foundation
then you can go on both and then she's
going to say oh we're going to continue
the investigation of trump right and
then every time she goes on cnn or msnbc
she gets asked for donations and then
later we'll find out how much uh foreign
governments are spending into this it's
gonna be 2045 yeah and we're going to be
all moved beyond this and she's going to
be sitting in a rocking chair in her
house with a bunch of cats being like
trump but you understand that there's a
group of people that there's a group of
people out there and this overlaps with
sort of the
um the true crime fad that's going on
right now where it's it's just the let's
get trump tv show and right and this is
like season six and they don't even care
what the underlying bit is it's just we
gotta go get him isn't the guy who
produced the the primetime show for the
democrats from abc yeah he's the same
guy who like shot down the epstein story
yeah this is a reality tv show no but
just i want to make sure i'm clearing
that that was the guy right same
producer the same producer who who
blocked the epstein
story on it
did the democrats think
that it's kind of amazing how you like
if we we need to start doing six degrees
of epstein yeah we might not even we
might not even need six it's like two
okay and the
judge who signed off on it uh you know
on the warrant was the lawyer for
epstein's pilot and his lieutenant and
one degree there we go who and then
tomorrow he's holding the hearing on the
after remember
that uh that uh epic viral video from
the alex jones trial where the lawyer is
like you're claiming that the government
is involved with trafficking and he goes
like oh you mean like what the epstein's
did with clinton or whatever millionaire
i've seen and then the
thug life sunglasses
it it doesn't matter what you say if a
pair of 8-bit sunglasses appear on your
face right well i just i just think it's
funny that we have known now i think for
a couple of years at the biden
administration a couple years like since
the last year i guess a year and a half
that the biden administration has been
trafficking children into the u.s
and then you get people who start saying
things like i think the government is
involved in child trafficking and
they're like oh you're a conspiracy
theorist and it's like
did cnn reported this
like
there's videos night flights night
flights
they take these kids on the board they
put them on planes and they fly them all
across the country to random places and
then there are stories about like these
kids going to these shelters and
shelters are over overwhelmed and
they're like we don't know what to do
with all these kids why are they being
sent to us
yeah that's that's what the bite
administration is doing but if your
world is only what you see on msnbc in
that alternate universe of reality you
know what are they to believe
i i think a lot about desensitization
lately i was smelling something so
stinky the other day that all of a
sudden i like shook my head and i
smelled nothing i was like it was so bad
my brain didn't even want me to
understand
experience it to perceive it so you were
able to smell yourself i smelled yes i
swear i think it was only chickens
um and it's the same with like seeing
some horrible violence and then the
person's like i don't even remember what
i saw kind of thing they people know
that their government is involved in
trafficking children around the country
maybe even around the world i don't know
how deep it goes but it's like so
horrific that i think people are like
their minds aren't well keep in mind
that the epstein's story was considered
a conspiracy theory for years yeah and
if you brought that up you were crazy
you were nuts if you said that which we
all knew that he was very close to the
clintons he was to go around saying that
he was one of the initial founders of
the clinton global initiative
and
ties to you know harvard and bill gates
all this other stuff right and so it was
so crazy that
people just couldn't they couldn't wrap
their heads around it but then when all
of that came out suddenly post epstein
it's like all right if that were true
then what else could possibly be true
let me well the russia hoax could be
true the covet issues could have been
true i mean all these things become
conspiracy theories
i want to jump to this story here and
give a shout out to the man the myth the
legend alex jones because uh
he was right about epstein if you're
listening to this you are the resistance
that's right he was uh he was right
about epstein i remember when uh when
the episode story broke joe rogan was
like dude alex jones was right yeah and
it's it's like it's crazy because alex
has gone on joe's show and said really
crazy stuff
chimeras 5g towers whatever
interdimensional beings
and then he says some of these other
stories like the epstein thing and
you're like people don't want to believe
it and it turns out to be true
we got the story from bloomberg
being thrown off social media was
supposed to end alex jones's career it
made him even richer
i think this is an important story for
one they admit or at least they're
asserting they wanted jones it was
supposed to it is right there in the
headlines it was supposed to
stop the spread of violence sorry that's
right like they just admitted they just
straight up admit we were trying to end
his career they said initially it was
because he was promoting violence and
they had to stop it for the safety now
it's it was supposed to end his career
now you've got in the in the court case
against them you had the the lawyer uh
for the families say
don't just
punish him destroy his platform and make
sure he can't rebuild it but i think
this is a big story they claim that alex
jones is worth a lot of money alex jones
has commented to me on the story saying
that he does not in fact have this much
money he is not making this money this
much money they're bankrupt and he's
broke
look i know he said that but i kind of
find it hard to believe that someone
who's had such a powerful media empire
would not have saved up money somewhere
set up trusts with his family or
something so maybe personally yes he is
broke but a lot of a lot of that wealth
probably transferred out through various
trusts or other other other ways to you
know family members there was a story in
the new york post that he transferred a
portion of property to his wife or
something i don't know the fact is this
story is a white pill
the fact that they are so desperate to
stop alex jones
and they can't yeah it shows that
well alex despite all of the things
they've thrown at him and and that the
damage they have caused to his business
he's persisted he survived and he's been
effective the reason they're going after
him is because he's one of the most
effective supporters of trump or was
and that he's influential
this i think at the same time the white
pill that they i think the fbi going
after trump that doesn't it makes me a
little bit pessimistic in terms of civil
war take a drink everybody but it makes
me actually optimistic in terms of the
upcoming elections they are so panicked
about
the influence of people like jones the
influence of people like trump that
they're desperately pulling moves like
this it's a whack-a-mole they've been
freaked out since 2007 when they
realized that an internet video blogger
on youtube could rally 500 000 people to
vote for whoever they want uh the cnn
got involved in 2007 we're like we're
gonna do the cnn youtube debates all
right kids all you super influential new
famous young people that are way more
powerful than we are let's
create an authority so we can kind of
make a semblance of controlling you and
so they did these lame-ass youtube
debates with cnn where they like
wouldn't i tried to ask questions about
the federal reserve and they like just
would ignore that of course
we talk about obama's favorite foods and
things like that
they're in complete
hanging by a thread the global financial
market i didn't know what globalists
were the liberal international economy
yeah that's it the lie i love it but
i remember back in the day like i said
back in the day but 10 years ago
obama did the reddit ama they asked me
anything it was like a big deal
but he only answered like what ten
questions and they were very stocked
like
what would you do with tech with health
care
we're gonna give more of that we like it
what started changing is that i think
people are sick of the obvious lies
remember deepwater horizon
south park may have made a joke about
how the uh the the bp guy goes on tv and
he goes we're so so sorry we're sorry
sorry when when that happens
does any reasonable person believe
they're going to tell the truth does any
sane person think that gen saki or uh
you know jean-pierre are going to come
out and just be like totally honest with
the american people and for that matter
spicer or you know sarah sanders for
instance i don't expect any of them to
come out and just blatantly tell me the
truth about what's going on not a
republican not a democrat not not
trump's people there's there's obvious
legitimate reasons why they can't tell
you the truth for good or bad right we
can't leak secrets if we have plans we
need to compartmentalize and make sure
our plans are you know if we wanted
something good we can't just go out and
explain exactly what we're doing if i'm
for instance going to be suing some some
organization
and i think it's a really good thing and
it needs to happen well coming out and
explaining in detail what i'm doing just
helps them and stops me from doing it so
for obvious reasons you're just not
getting the truth but what happens is
with people like alex jones
they feel authenticity and that was a
big shift whether jones was right or
wrong
you you th the dude believes what he's
saying oh he's right a lot of times
he talked about the globalists in like
2005 and six i was like okay i think
he's being a little hyperbolic he's
being vague what the heck is he even
talking about but now i find out that
there's like
multinational corporations where they
have their headquarters in one country
but all their activity are a bulk of
their activities in another country
they're basically tax evading uh and
that's a huge i mean that's what he's
talking about he's talking about he's
talking about like world economic forum
crap
remember uh i don't know how if you guys
have been watching or listening to alex
jones for a long time by chance
i don't know but i remember so i've been
on the internet my whole life
i remember the loose change virality
moment where people were burning loose
changing element of discs and like
sharing them around with everybody well
so um when i was in college i remember
that yeah the ron paul was like yeah
you'd have to lose change guys or be
around yeah i told this to alex jones uh
the first time he came on the show i was
like i remember when you were ragging on
a real id when you were like yeah
they're going to be federalizing ids
this is what it means and he was raising
alarm bells about it and the potential
problems and what happens is we're frogs
in a pot the pot is boiling and we don't
realize how much has really changed but
i remember now a few years ago i go to
the airport and there's all the signs
everywhere get your real id update your
ids otherwise you're not compliant
so he was right about it and he said it
would do a bunch of things that it does
because he was reading the news and
reporting it accurately now we're in it
real id is here and nobody cares
everyone's just like oh i got my id my
id updated whatever so he he talks about
the the incrementalization one small
grain of sand at a time and before you
realize that your whole world is
different well just think about this you
go to the store at walmart or wherever
you make some purchases on your credit
card all that data is there you go
online again on walmart and you look and
you say here's all the things you've
been buying do you want any more of
those
when the fbi wants data on you they just
send a letter to at t or to walmart or
to chase bank and they request that data
yep
and they have your whole life right
there your credit cards your purchases
where you were at apparently uh the
phone companies have been giving
people's text messages
to uh to like the january 6 committee
and stuff like that well this came up
also with ring camera
that a lot of people that so the the
issue that came up was that police
departments ice other agencies
were
able to access ring without the
permission of
the but like derek saying just going to
the company directly and of course the
companies are saying hey we're we're
trying to prevent crimes what if there's
a um you know a child grabbing incident
and we caught it on bring camera you
know would you want to notify the
authorities right away but then the
question and you could say well yeah i
mean i think there's some utility to
that obviously but then the question of
course becomes
how much are they watching or they do
they know when you come in and out of
your home do they know who's coming in
and out of your home well that's
metadata so yes yeah that's all of it
the crazy thing about metadata and this
is i think it's been a while but i'm
pretty sure brett kavanaugh ruled in
favor of the government's ability to use
metadata as not as a violation of the
fourth amendment but i could be wrong
about that it's been a while since i was
doing research in that regard but the
thing about metadata is the argument is
when you walk outside your house anyone
can see you do it right so that's not
right you have no expectation of privacy
if the police are sitting in public and
they watch you leave your home they now
know you left your home well that's too
bad the argument was that with metadata
when you visit websites
you're not hiding yourself you're not
there's no there's no expectation of
privacy when your computer sends a
request out anyone who wants can see it
the problem is
with metadata it's not just about
watching you leave your house we watch
your house we can guess where you're
going is it going to work what time is
it i don't know it's not going to work
maybe he's going to get food where is it
going to go i don't know
with metadata they can tell when you're
going to poop and i'm not i'm not
kidding
there was an article about how facebook
accurately predicts when people have to
make movements as it were because they
have all this metadata they know when
you put your phone down they know when
you're walking they know when you're
likely eating they can calculate all
this stuff and now the government can
easily get access to all of that the one
that i saw that was very similar to that
was um pregnancies that they could base
they could base based on your google
searches basically you know you're
saying i'm telling you you know i have
these symptoms what's going on and the
case study that i remember reading was a
girl
had gotten some ads in the mail for you
know like folic acid and basic pregnancy
stuff from coupons from the local target
because she was a frequent shopper there
they knew she was pregnant before she
did and the dad is the one who saw it
and said right what yeah and he called
why are you sending my daughter and they
were like oh that was right
right right it was like an algorithm
that i remember she didn't know she was
pregnant but she was buying things yes
that they just knew
and so this was the pattern that led you
to big brother
knows big brother knows when you'll poop
before you do you know what concerns me
is we're talking about the fourth
amendment rights and is it a violation
of fourth remembrance but i think it's
so far beyond american government at
this point that when we complain about
what the american government the united
states american government is doing it's
kind of like just complaining about what
one of the lieutenants is doing because
everyone all these governments have the
ability to scrape your metadata it
doesn't matter they don't have the ccp
doesn't have a fourth amendment to
violate they just do whatever they want
so reality it is harder in a certain
sense for the ccp to get access to our
data than the us government because the
us government has authority over these
organizations they just call it barracks
wall oil they just buy it yeah so the
ccp through any one of the companies
they control can just buy the data
and then they know just
it's part of the contract it gives them
access to it and that's what we've seen
in some of our investigations not only
that but let's talk about 23andme and
how much that is getting sourced by
china
so i'll say i'll tell you why is it why
do you guys think 23andme is that cheap
come on they're selling they're selling
all that stuff i was good i was i was at
a party and i'll keep the story as vague
as possible and i was talking to someone
about um wait tim you promised me you
would never shh
i was talking to somebody about covet
testing and i said something like you
know the the problem with the mass
testing is the concern that china is
going to get access to this this dna
information and then someone else
overheard
you know basically was like oh it's
conspiracy it's fake news
you know you can't go around saying
these things when people hear pay
attention to the news and knows what's
going on you're lying blah blah i just
took my phone i pulled up the npr
article that says
china is getting access to data testing
and they were like uh well i'm like dude
like i do this for a living right i'm
not making these stories up i'm reading
the news and that's that's that's a lot
for uh i would say the same is true for
alex jones i think the issue with alex
though is that
he stretches things a little too far and
what i mean by that is atrazine was the
big story uh interfering with the
endocrine systems of frogs and then he
yells at turning the frogs that was a
big problem they were turning them they
were making them hermaphroditic meaning
the
sex organs of the male and the female
they weren't gay and he said that they
were turning them gay like the problem
with alex and is that over time is that
he's also he leans into the
entertainment the jokester are just bad
for sure here's okay but explain this to
me why does the rachel maddow standard
not apply to alex jones oh right why is
it that when you when i forget who it
was but they were suing rachel maddow
over this and
they and then she came in and said well
this is an opinion show everything
everything i say is my opinion and the
judge rules okay well then it's all
covered well for alex i don't even care
about legality stuff that's not what i
meant when i was saying the problem i
just i'm concerned like why why he's
looked at as ridiculed by as he has been
by societies because he does both the
jokes and the news
so so this one thing that happened when
he was being sued i think is that
he claimed he was acting and then the
the left came out and they were like
and he was like no he does commercials
there's a commercial where he rips his
shirt off and then scott and then flies
through the ceiling of his building the
commercial right yeah yeah he actually
does
he turned red come on i i do want to
shout out yeah that that ad where he's
like a redder you know the ones like
before and after but yeah
was that real i don't know
it was hilarious either way my favorite
one it was the doctor i forget who it
was but he he takes the super male
vitality and goes i will now activate my
muscles by doing push-ups
and then he just like tears his shirt
off and starts doing push-ups and he
comes up and he's got he's turned into
like a werewolf
and then he says he's acting and then
yeah you know it's funny when i see it i
see
i talk to regular people or i see
facebook posts from a lot of these
lefties they don't know anything about
the guy they don't know they don't know
they sit there blindly believing the
lies it's it's it's remarkable to me
that after all of the lies these people
still don't wake up and it's got to be
willful well it's a double standard all
the time we see with the media you know
one standard for liberals another
standard for conservatives but you know
this this issue that you're touching on
i think you know strikes home to a lot
of our listeners
yeah well and and when i bring up rachel
maddow it's it's not necessarily to to
point out that it's double standard in
terms of the way society presents them
but now you've got a situation in the
united states where you're creating and
and derek you talk about this all the
time this two-tiered system of justice
where one one standard can apply to alex
jones and you can ruin him and take away
his entire career because he got a story
wrong but rachel maddow is perfectly
fine to say whatever she wants because
it's her opinion
we need parallel economies
so shout out to dan bongino's parallel
yeah shout out to rumble and shout out
to public square public square love it
if you guys haven't downloaded public
square
yeah public square is uh an app
that shows you all the businesses that
that believe in your values and all that
stuff so we i'm thinking about i agree
with you on video the peril the
parallelity that we do need like 2007
internet video you could tell that the
young video bloggers were taking control
of society what it does the government
the federal government have that we
don't like if we were to create like
just the army they had the army they
have like the tax
code system 87 000 armed irs agents who
are trained to kill poor people so it's
all like military it's all like guns and
enforcement they control like the
enforcers they have the stick and that's
they is just like what the executive
branch in congress basically you don't
want to give that i don't want to give
that stuff to the populace no it's not
just the executive branch in congress
that's that's the problem though is it's
supposed to be the executive branch in
congress backstop by the judiciary but
the problem with all of this is that you
have an administrative state that has
grown and become the fourth branch of
government that's who liz cheney is
campaigning for that's your msnbc your
cnn plug-in right there they're tied
into academia they're tied into the
entire education system they're tied
into the defense industrial complex this
is that fourth branch of government that
was never supposed to be do you think
it's that we need it to no exist within
this global system of like totalitarian
governments vying for control absolutely
not then do you think it's like i mean
we need we you need a military right you
need a military industry you need
industry to keep up with that military
sure but the the power should always be
with the representatives and you have a
congress that's completely abrogated
that because most congressmen or a lot
of them not gonna say all of them but
they would rather go raise money and
hang out on the golf course and then do
whatever the lobbyist wants it's the
rule-making and enforcement mechanisms
of of
epa or department of education with new
rules and executive orders on lots of
different issues that affect our our
kids going to school it's a doj and fbi
being immune from real oversight and
control
by the executive branch the president
whether it was president trump or
whether it's
bill biden who says i don't know what's
going on no one's talked to me
by the way we do have a little bit of
breaking news on the liz cheney front oh
you guys want it yeah so washington post
has a
a sort of pr they're they're setting the
stage so it's a sage setting article
because we're about 20 minutes away from
what's closing here let me pull it up
what's the title um it is bracing for
loss liz chaney says primary is
beginning of the battle so what's going
on here is that her press her press team
has has pumped this out they want this
to be the narrative
and even though she may not win she's
building her campaign into a nationwide
movement to stop donald trump uh there
it is and there it there it is i'm
telling you that's exactly what this is
the sea the show must go on the show
must go because the the stop trump
movement has become a proxy war of the
establishment versus the people and they
have they're using the avatar of trump
the the specter of trump as the you know
the great orange whale as a way to get
you to
to derek's point to sacrifice your civil
liberties to go after the political
opposition whether you're someone and
and if you are someone who's an
effective voice against uh an actual
opposition voice by the way i don't mean
you know arguing about one of the little
things that there that they let you
argue about i mean actually stepping up
against the regime they will strike you
down
we just watched the show trial steve
bannon let me jump to the story uh from
the new york times alaska's voters will
try out changes to primary and special
elections so
they've got a rank choice voting
and uh well they say voters in alaska on
tuesday will test for the first time a
new ranked choice system for a general
election in a special race for the state
single house seat and they will take
part in the state's new open primary
system which was first deployed during a
special house primary in june that
combination right there sounds like
uh
it's
let's put it this way we're not changing
the elections we're making it better
they changed the rules
open primaries i think are bad i used to
not understand why it mattered now i
totally get it because democrats can
vote in the republican primary to
sabotage the republican party so that
when it comes to the general nobody
wants to vote for the republican like if
the democrats vote for liz cheney and
she ends up winning republicans are
going to be like whatever and then a
democrat wins wyoming that'd be that'd
be crazy
now we have ranked choice voting i'm
actually
i've been a fan of it for a while but
one thing interesting that comes up with
the way they're doing it now to consider
it is widely believed or actually jack
was mentioning it just before the show
that this is going to help murkowski
maintain her seat do you want to explain
because in rank choice voting if someone
doesn't break the threshold then it then
they start counting the second choice
votes and so this will end up so if all
of your maga vote for example is
targeted to one candidate and then
they're never going to say the
establishment candidate as number two
you'll you will always see democrats or
soft conservative soft republicans uh
your one of fours or even your 404s who
are more establishment types they will
put murkowski as their second choice so
she'll pick up a wider swath of voters
meanwhile a mega conservative is never
going to say they want a democrat as
their second choice but so so in the
we're in a primary right now so people
aren't voting for
democrat they're voting for just the
republicans
wouldn't they just be more does it only
apply to does it only apply to the
primary well no but here's my point for
now
wouldn't more people be like okay well
you know this candidate's not likely
going to win but they're my first pick
and then i guess if i had to take
murkowski as my fifth choice i would
and i feel like in a primary it's open
primary which is the biggest risk right
if you if you do rank choice voting yeah
you're going to get all the populists
being like man i really would prefer
this guy right here
they might think he's not going to win
so i can't vote for him with ranked
choice voting they'll be like yeah i'll
i'll give my first choice and look
project veritas and rc maxwell the great
journalist over there did a whole piece
on this how was murkowski staffers that
actually left her campaign and then
stood up this other organization to push
through
ranked choice voting because she as a
candidate right couldn't directly get
behind it and then after it went in they
went back to the campaign so the idea is
in the general election what will happen
is
republicans will say
i guess i'll vote for murkowski and my
second choice are going to be these
other you know candidates write-ins or
maybe you know maga people but the
democrats will put murkowski as their
fifth choice right so when all of their
people lose if murkowski is in the lead
she's going to get all the democrat
votes
along with the the establishment votes
so it makes it impossible for
the republicans to get in populists
basically look and i've said this before
and i i don't think gang has it right
you know if you're going to start a
third party a real third party in this
country you have to do it within the
party structure that's already existing
and there is a third party in this
country and it's called maga that is a
third party it just happens to be inside
the republican party yeah i mean you've
got the the left
bernie party or whatever inside the
democrat party one of the things that's
happening across the country in the
republican party is there are so many
new people getting involved you know
homemakers and small business people
that are deciding freezing project the
precinct project that's absolutely right
and small groups picking up patriot moms
voices of washington county or voices of
this county people are getting involved
and they are
get going to school board meetings but
many are deciding to run for these
obscure offices because they all matter
and that's the building block of that
future party jack and these are almost
all very conservative principled valued
people that supported donald trump
when people get into local offices like
you're talking about is it the kind of
thing where they have to quit their
their day gig
not usually not usually not for local
offices
so how does that work right so you're
you're you just won the primary for
county commissioner is that right
yes and i'm going up against a democrat
in the fall and if i do get elected in
the fall
technically it's a part-time job but
it's a full-time demanding job if you're
going to do your job correctly
it does pay a salary of about 38 000 a
year but you're voting and managing a
budget of nearly 800 million dollars
across the board for the county wow so
it takes
a full-time effort to go to meetings to
go to commissions you know there's a
couple dozen commissions that are you
know elderly commission there's the
women's commission there's zoning water
commissions those things that you have
to be aware of what's going on and lots
of issues are coming forward
and you're and you're trying to get the
job to manage 800 million dollars for a
thirty thousand dollar salary this is
the challenge of politics right now that
is that is an ince i could not imagine
trying to manage uh manage a budget like
that and you effectively have to do it
for free you have to really really want
that job you gotta care about your
county your hometown the future of your
kids yeah adorable or throw it away and
just make sure that some of that
millions goes to people you know
no i was just going to say that that
yeah you're exactly right that in on the
flip side of this for people that aren't
maybe
already independently wealthy or have a
you know a stable career outside of this
that that's where that's where bribery
and that's where money comes in because
they'll say hey you know sign off in the
zoning board for us this happened in my
hometown with um
you know we lost a golf course to out to
a hospital that nobody wanted and the
the this was this wasn't county level
this was um
township level and they went the the
company went in and just bankrolled a
couple of democrats that wanted that
would vote for the hospital and then got
him on board boom golf course gone
hospital in there you go
and and that's it that's the way this
system works
i remember when i was uh younger i
noticed that all these skate parks that
were popping up were garbage just like
the worst and i just didn't understand
why i was like why are they so bad
because they're the x games they
obviously have good ramps why aren't
those companies making it yeah there was
a community meeting in one of the
neighborhoods
where a local construction company was
like it's going to cost you know half a
million dollars to build this park
and then as the story goes
some guy grabbed his phone and put on
speaker one of the big top tier
companies that makes all the big parks
and they said we can do this for a
hundred that's ridiculous but the city
still went with the guy who said 500.
what i was told was that in many of
these circumstances in the city the
people who build skateparks have no idea
how to build them but
they're the lobbyists they're the
companies that fund the local
politicians so when they come they call
up and say look i need a favor you got
the budget to build it we can build it
you know go with us you know we support
and say okay fine what's the harm it's a
construction company they know how to
build a skate park we'll go with them
they're here anyway then what happens
they don't know how to build a park
skate parks are very specific and you
get dangerous garbage parks and you're
wondering why man i got to tell you they
built this one park
that uh they built the dimensions of the
bowl run so a bowl is like it's like a
like a pool right you've got multiple
you know transition ramps that go around
an edge and they built them so compact
and tight
one guy i remember i was skating
did not know it was built wrong
and if you've been skating you know most
ramps usually are built correctly so you
just ride around and you know how to
make your moves and he went up to carve
between these two walls and they were
built like a 90 like it was like a wall
and he slammed into it bashed his skull
and was left blood in the ground
that is because
and this is what i'm told
the city decided to go with a crony over
an actual construction company that's
what happens with cronyism you're saying
like with regarding cronyism so like
they'll say uh corporation will be like
we're going to fund these democrats to
make sure that our skate park gets built
so if you were the county commissioner
would there be other people on the
commission with you it's a five-person
commission
and it's a majority vote that will make
the determination on a budget or an
issue of a purchase for the sheriff's
department like new equipment or for the
fire department because it's fire it's
fire and rescue ems
sheriff's department those are all under
the county and your role be one of five
one of five
so how does that how does that work when
people vote like it says vote for five
county commissioners there's a big list
right
wow that's crazy yeah all right well
good luck
so you you are you're but you're not
just up against one democrat then are
you no no there's multiple democrats so
and
in some ways you could say you're up
against other republicans right because
it's it's a food fight at that point so
what is the top five
it's it's a it's a top five and you know
in washington county tim as you know
it's a heavily republican it was a trump
county by about 61 percent manga country
maga country yep and you know we've got
people that really care about their
their county and the future here and
we've got a great slate of good
candidates across the board but then in
um
i just remember from back home my county
was uh you would have to do you have to
have certain number of minority seats
no there's no requirement for
any identity politicians and i'm pretty
sure washington county sent a letter
requesting to secede from maryland to
join west virginia
yes they did
that's the percentage
yes tim that letter was
sent and received is that like actually
on the table
i mean
it there was it was like three counties
right western maryland well i i find
that the succession idea
to be a major distraction from our
ability to actually work on the heart
issues that we have an opportunity to
make progress on
did you see the uh the districts change
with the new census yes they but by
cutting out
basically what what was it they they had
uh the frederick suburbs in
the the the western uh maryland
congressional district congressional
district for western maryland is the
sixth congressional district and we got
david trone running against neil parrott
in for the um
uh congressional seat here
and by the way david trone does not live
within the district okay and you're
allowed to do that you're allowed to do
that here okay and the other issue is
you know the gerrymandering was
challenged in court and it came out a
little bit better for republicans
because of the court cases brought by
neil parrott and others so but we do
have it's like a republican district now
it wasn't it's still a majority democrat
district because we've got
parts of the dc suburbs as part of this
district that represents all the way out
to the very end of of western maryland
wow so very dissimilar areas wow this is
cd uh maryland six cd6 maryland maryland
sixth congressional district
yeah
it's uh d plus one wow that's crazy but
it's
much better opportunity and it is looked
at as a very competitive race that the
republicans can flip this year
oh wait wait wait
oh it's changed it's still d plus one
but moving forward they've included
frederick in wow
that's that's just crazy to me i mean
you've got people who live in the
panhandle of maryland who are i mean
it's my country
i go driving out there it is all maga
country it's it's basically west
virginia it's rural
yet they are are in what's basically a
dc suburb we've got montgomery county as
part of
part of this district wow you guys
mentioned
multiple times say the word maga's come
up and jack even mentioned earlier that
it was oh oh honest jack's best
yeah that there is a third political
party in the united states it's maga but
it's just in the republican party so why
don't they break ranks and start another
political party called maga
why would they because people the reason
i've heard in the past is because it no
they need the money they need that
republican money but no they no they
don't they need fame they need
popularity so it's infrastructure yeah
what does that mean
it's it's the infrastructure of what 9
thousand different municipalities across
the entire country
that do what exactly that do everything
that he's talking about from the ground
up
it's county county commission not county
commissioners but you know washington
county in maryland you've got a central
committee republicans that help organize
recruit develop
precinct
captains recruit precinct leaders
to register voters all of that
infrastructure is gradually being taken
over by maga yes so if i went to a
county i'm sorry i have to issue a
correction it's nuclear ultra magazine
wait wait wait with with with the side
infusion of of extremist roads right
yeah not not just not just the rosary
but the gadsden flag and
betsy ross flag the gonzalez flag yeah
so if i went to i love that story by the
way the story of the gonzalez flag
that's crazy you know the story is i
looked it up
it was a small it was the colony of
gonzales they had what they they
requested armaments they got one cannon
and then the mexican colonels whatever
showed up and said give us your cannon
and they were like no come and take it
and they held up a flag with their one
little cannon on it like drew a picture
of it it's amazing so great that's all
it was if i went to a county
with my with my you know gaston flag
wrapped around me and i was like i'm an
ultra mega nuclear candidate i want to
run they'd be like we don't have the
infrastructure for you because it's all
republican like what what would be the
difference exactly like how would i have
a hard time getting on the ballot what
would be different
because i'm making youtube videos i got
100 million people that follow me on
youtube for the sake like do you
remember when we talked to the mises
caucus guys and they're talking about
the libertarian party and the
pragmatists and then the mises guys come
in basically took the party over
you've got a party there are people in
it who have ideals so basically what
ends up happening is there's a monopoly
on the political on the political
infrastructure between democrats and
republicans
and it's it's going to be impossible for
you to compete with you know you're
trying to open a
coffee shop next to a starbucks good
luck bro they got all they could
subsidize everything democrats can take
money from wealthy districts send it
over to your district and flood the zone
so you can't possibly win but unless
you've got a comparably large so instead
of opening a coffee shop you franchise a
coffee bean to open up next to starbucks
and you got to give some of your profits
and so yeah but now you're going to do
things the way you want to do it it's
all money it's all money so it's not
just money it's everything it's also
because the united states has a winner
take all system and not proportional
representation right and so this is why
you see more multi-party coalitions in
europe or um and there's different uh
different parts of the world that have
proportional representation because then
you can have
uh if a certain amount of people in the
country vote for that party then they
can get on the ballot that's closer to
what you're talking about so ian it's
actually really really simple
there is a third party the way jack
describes it but what happens is you've
got republicans republicans
overwhelmingly share similar values
one day someone comes up and says hey we
all kind of agree that immigration is an
issue
why don't we put that on our agenda list
to fix the border
established republicans are like no
that's bad for my lobbyists it's bad for
my corporate donors or whatever or i
don't agree with it
but one day you wake up to find that 60
percent of your party agrees we should
secure the border all of a sudden now
you're seeing a new a change of the
candidate's style and and and the way
they talk and the ideas they promote
because they have a higher priority on
issues that their party already kind of
cares like are they getting marching
orders they're like hey now sixty
percent of the head of the rnc wants
this so then listen
it's it's it's it's also
a new generation a new generation
entered the political uh entered the
republican party and if you look at you
know someone like me i didn't vote for
trump in 2016 and voted in 2020. but i i
came from the internet the internet
position of like the hacker culture and
freedom and liberty and anarchy and
things like that so when you're getting
all these ron paul young people that
grew up on the internet they're not
going to be democrats they're going to
be republicans and then
when when they start running you'll see
a ron desantis and the party starts
changing and when you if you go back
historically just for comparison
purposes you know in the late 1950s and
early 60s you know the republican party
you know after eisenhower
went into the dark ages and you know
minority in in the house of
representatives
you know we had democratic presidents
but we had a revolution within the
republican party
started with conservative writers and
thinkers it led to barry goldwater
running he lost
really badly
but it provided the seed corn for what
became ronald reagan and the ronald
reagan revolution it took
20 years
but they took over the party
from
the establishment we're going through
the same metamorphosis here in my
judgment
well keep in mind that but people always
talk about you know the barry watergate
goal we're getting blown out but that's
also because that was one year after
uh the jfk assassination and i think
that had a lot more to do with it than
his any specific ideology um just just
to kind of throw that out there but
as tim and i were talking about early on
twitter today
this is why there is an opening in the
2024 race for none other than
ron paul get him in there yeah trump ron
paul 2015. why trump why not why not
well because all right so because
remember trump isn't i mean i'm a fan
but isn't ron like 90. 80 i think 83
something 88 maybe really
no because here's all right here's my
thinking here's my thinking and and
people are saying oh trump wants a woman
trump wants
this 86 okay um why not
you know wind up cause choose someone
younger set them up hold on though hold
on all right all right let me let me let
me give the the pitch here
trump can only have one term left so
this isn't going to be someone who's got
a two-term presidency
and me i'm looking at it from the
perspective of you know i'm just kind of
playing out the argument i'm not like
actually saying we need to do this um
but we want somebody who's going to get
in there and actually clean things up
and wouldn't that be more interesting if
you knew that the person on your team
also wasn't considering having a future
career go on to do more in politics that
you could bring a guy in who wasn't
worried about the future because um you
know he's pretty much at the end of his
career to begin with
and go in and actually clean house i
mean yes i would absolutely take a ron
paul government over
99.9 of any of these politicians so
sure it's not a bad idea rand paul as
well i'm just imagining ron getting in
and being like oh the first thing i'm
going to do is end the fed then trump's
like whatever you say ron and then
everyone shares and ian has a party
great
and
there you go i mean yeah it'd be great
i'm concerned about it don't audit it
abolish it i would like to talk to ron
before i before i decide because 86
concerns me 86 is that what it was 86.
yeah it is but as a vp i mean look it's
vp right you know it's now we're talking
the criteria you're talking about is is
good someone who's not going to be
focusing on their own political future
yes someone who's got competency and
experience in government
uh someone who's independent enough and
not worried about being attacked by the
mainstream media or whatever so
you know that sounds good for the vice
president for the vice president for the
vice president it might be someone else
out there who fits those criteria
like when obama picked biden
and advisor that went to run for brexit
because i'm trying to think of of what's
the most effective vice president i
could think of which and by the way on
in terms of all that you
could also throw rand paul in that mix
yeah um for the same reason no i i would
think that he would probably also
consider a political power beyond that i
would prefer trump rand paul over trump
desantis
um i'd say rand paul yeah yeah for for
one yeah i think the pauls as a family
are principled great people i think rand
paul would be a great vp i don't think
he's got what it takes to be a president
you've had him on right he's been on
here no no no really yeah get him on oh
you should come on yeah
look dude rand paul is like one of the
only guys who stands up to the ndaa and
and tries to filibuster these bills
absolutely how about a desantis and don
jr took it oh i mean that'd be great
yeah you know you get the the trump name
and and backing and then you got
desantis and you don't have sannis
desantis 28 and then don jr runs for i'm
thinking either senate or governor in
florida
i do not like families controlling
things i don't mind if the person's
qualified like rand paul's he's he's won
me over with his good graces and his
interactions but i don't like voting for
names like i don't know don jr if he has
any it's political aspiration or quality
i don't i've never met the guy you're
right but don jr has shown that he has
good values i just don't want to vote oh
well that's a different story i will not
vote for a name though we get to we
we've been out there working
to vote for baron
well that's another story
i don't know he's tall he's like what's
that like dude 12 feet tall
now yeah whoa
yeah the story of baron trump is told by
baron trump yeah
a story about a guy named what is it
barron trump just hit 9 o'clock by the
way and uh so does that are the results
coming in what's going on uh polls just
closed but i don't think we have results
yet but we should get close to wyoming
there should be some polling alaska is
still going by the way sarah palin also
on the ballot today in alaska special
elections in congress up there kind of
kind of incredible so she's i think
she's i believe she's the front runner
for that you know strange and then kelly
chewbacca by the way if we haven't said
her name yeah i just searched baron
trump um on brave browser and a lot of
the pictures of him are like when he was
a little kid still where's all the
pictures of baron today he's taller than
his dad he's a giant can you set it for
like you know yeah
2022 and then set it first i have a
feeling he's big and beautiful now and
the media doesn't want to show how
wonderful a trump man can become like
the tallest
he looks like his dad so there's a book
that was written in the 1800s
about a guy who runs for president named
barron trump and in the book they
actually say that anarchists and
socialists come from the lower east side
of manhattan to trump castle on fifth
avenue
and like i i can't believe it you know
what i mean like it just doesn't does
not sound real
my my favorite ingersoll lockwood yeah
that's the
i've talked about i think i've said this
on here before but my favorite uh my
favorite one of those theories is that
um
is that stevie
so that bannon actually is baron from
the future who has been who has been
sent back to guide his father
and i guess that the time dilation
affects the height and the reason
trump fired bannon right uh in 17 yeah
yeah so what ended up happening was
uh
uh donald overheard bannon talking with
his contacts through his future
communications device because it's
really easy to talk to the future right
obviously and then uh well you keep the
channel he knows too much about him no
he walked in it was like
steve what is this what are you saying
you're barren and he's like dad you
weren't supposed to find out this way i
can't believe this get out of here
i would love to make that short film it
would be great i love you dad steve
bannon
from the future
so i don't know this these books are
crazy we talked about them before
but uh i don't know why why did barron
come oh yeah you said you're not gonna
say okay anyway back to the actual uh
news and stuff don don jr has gone on
numerous shows talked about his values
what he believes in what he wants
good book a good book too
right there you go so but he's worked
really hard in the campaigns
working to support candidates across the
board it works like crazy yeah so you're
not voting for a name you're voting for
a guy who's doing the work we should
have him on i think he follows you on
twitter we're talking about having him
on so we'll talk to him yeah
come on whenever he whenever he's able
to talk politics bro yeah yeah he's
he has been invited a lot of ideas of
things we could do to like refocus
people on on what we can do let's talk
about this a global coalition to work on
the carbon
dioxide here's a choice here we go
hunter biden
don john jr yeah compare and contrast
you know
it's crazy isn't it
if if don jr did one percent of what
hunter biden's accused of they'd be
calling for
you know a life prison sentence they'd
be saying lock him up well i i always
try to say that it
hunter biden is who they want don jr to
be right it's always projection for them
it's always projection
yeah i mean well it's deflection right
they know that they are doing something
wrong or it describes them so they have
to well that's you that's you no that's
you uh uh donald trump engaged in a quid
pro quo with ukraine it's like uh trump
actually uncovered biden's quid pro quo
with ukraine no no that was you well
it's actually the best way to get ahead
of so in politics the best way to get
ahead of a scandal is to accuse your
opponent of doing the same thing before
it's come out
so
you accuse them of the even if it's
completely baseless you accuse your
opponent of doing this and nancy pelosi
has talked about the wrap up smear a
million times where and scott adams has
been talking about this recently
just reminding us of it where she
explains well first you make the
accusation and then you get uh someplace
to report the accusation and then you
get a reporter to go and question them
about the accusation and get them to
respond and now you've done the wrap-up
and then you get the fbi to have a leak
to their favorite reporters and to go
brief on the hill so that they get a
committee the gang of eight and then the
gang of eight then tells reporters that
oh we we have a serious allegation here
against mr trump right that's what yeah
you had a tweet where you said you
thought the affidavit would reveal the
fbi source was the mainstream media yeah
so and and people were asking me what i
meant by that tweet
it's going hyper viral and what i'm
doing is i'm just putting a parallel to
the events of the last six months and
then the raid on mar-a-lago
with the russiagate investigation
because that's essentially what it was
it was a bunch of yahoo news articles
and michael isakoff which were based on
leaks from fusion gps and these this
insane dossier story which you know a
lot of people know about this point but
you know i'm not going to go rehash all
of it but the idea was they were using
circular reporting in that they were to
what we basically just said derek
they're leaking things to the press that
they want reported and then the doj
because again the doj has to have some
kind of probable cause right so they are
making their own probable cause and then
you add in like you know some innuendo
you add in some whisper down the lane
some hearsay some rumors oh i heard he's
got documents uh sources stuffed in his
pants i heard he's got i oh this this
one you know uniform division of the
secret service and she saw a box that
died i remember the one
the new york times keeps talking about
this while we we subpoenaed the
surveillance tapes of mar-a-lago and it
shows that there were boxes going in and
out of a secure room
whoa
whoa
whoa but yeah i do that too it's called
cleaning my garage i've got boxes going
in and out this is what the media does
my favorite analogy is saying that
you can you'll see the news report
something like sources close to pelosi's
office say that she kicks dogs and then
they're like whoa source is close to her
office what you didn't say was the
source was the homeless guy sleeping in
the alley who has no real understanding
of what's going on inside but he is
close he's very close i am telling the
truth you misinterpreted what i was
saying that's your fault you know the
media always exaggerates and amplifies
the story and when we look at it we get
the real facts down the road if we ever
do get the real facts we go what was
that about that's the constant back
story on the russia hoax the nuclear
document story that just came out
washington post said you know that the
agents were looking for nuclear
documents sources say sources familiar
with the investigation agents carried
out said that they were looking for
documents related to nuke to to nuclear
uh no no nuclear documents whether those
are weapons and whether those are
american we don't know and i'm like okay
so what you reported is we know a guy
who knows a guy and we think he was
looking for documents something to do
with nukes
what about the nukes no idea and you
know a guy
okay i'm supposed to take that seriously
as as fact-based reporting as
responsible sorry dude and then it turns
out the search warrant was just overly
broad it wasn't specific purposely
overly broad because it's actually a
fishing expedition to see if they can
find something in the haystack of
documents there i gotta say though
that's a big white pill so scared
trump's gonna win i actually
um i actually do have a little bit of
authorization to say this that on the
way here today
i did get a phone call from trump's
lawyer from christina bob and people
have seen her all across the news lately
that you know that she's out there on
this and and look we um we both worked
together at oan in the past so i don't
think anybody knows a surprise to
anybody that we know each other and yes
we do still keep in contact and one
thing that she told me
while she so she's there at the
mar-a-lago raid
and she's talked about this in some
interviews already but what i asked her
as i said what did the fbi like how were
they acting
were they acting you know you know if
you got in their face they were gonna
arrest you or how are they and the
weirdest thing and she said
uh that i took it was so strange that
she said
they were acting as if we could keep the
whole thing quiet if we were all just
kind of cool about it
that they actually didn't think
that trump would tell people that he had
been raided what and i said why do you
think they
they thought that and she said i think
that they thought that he
he was worried that it or he might be
worried that it would make trump look
bad and where i'm saying
how did they not understand that this
makes you look bad when they're raiding
him or that this is donald trump and
then it's right the dudes
yeah and they specifically timed the
raid i understand from some of the
readings i i did that
they timed it on it
when trump would not be there because
they wanted to keep it on the down low
right and he's not usually there
somewhere to begin with right for this
because mar-a-lago's closed for the
seasons we're on the skeleton crew right
now
and when i talked to christine she said
look i i wasn't even there you know when
this whole thing started and she you
know tore down when she heard what it
was fine what's going on
got in their faces to say hey you know
what are you doing what what is all this
can you explain what's going on they
wouldn't tell her anything
um
and we've seen the search warrant and it
was you know completely perfunctory and
we of course over human events daily
with the first outlet to you know blah
blah blah
so the doj is blocking the affidavit
right now so the doj has said now think
about this merrick garland came up two
days later and said
we will
let the information known to the
american people he said that at his
press conference and his his at the
press conference of course though his
argument was basically that hey i'm the
government you can trust me
and
then a couple days later by the way
immediately after that when he walked
off the stage that's when we got
the leak about the nukes so somebody
pops that out right after he gets off
stage about nuclear weapons which is
just immediately gone there's been a
bunch of rumors that have been flying
since then is it about ukraine is it
about you know the iran deal
whatever
and
they're now fighting to keep the
affidavit under seal because they are
saying that if the affidavit becomes out
it will
injure their
investigation
and you'd think that if he were trying
to be serious about this and jonathan
turley had a piece up today
which i thought he was being a little
squishy with it but i agree with part of
it where he said look if this guy was
trying to be fair he'd at least say you
can you can release parts of it yeah
that you could release something to just
alleviate like the pressure valve just
alleviate a little bit of the pressure
let off some of the pressure
look there were some documents we were
worried about the security of it it had
some
so so derek for example one of the one
of the theories that you know myself and
other you know as a prior navy
intelligence officer one of the theories
that we had was could he have um pdbs uh
declassified copies of a pdb what's a
pdb so presidential's daily brief
presence
so a pdb now he might have it because he
wants a certain portion of it but
depending on the format it's in you
might have all sorts of cia reporting in
there codeword stuff special access pro
who knows right you could have a ton of
stuff in there
that you know would would be better
served if it were secured elsewhere
right so you know what kind of stuff
would be in the pdb well it could be
discussions about north korean nuclear
capabilities right or the discussions or
the thinking of north korea which we
only have because maybe we have a source
in kim jong-un's palace or inside the
kremlin and if you read the report you
might know
that because of the access you know the
only way someone could have this level
of information and you know oh and kim
jong-un over breakfast on wednesday said
this the problem with that is on the
pdbs is the pd books are controlled they
go in and they are returned and they're
numbered right so
but i i really think that one of the
things that they had down there were
the
uh russia hoax documents from the cia
showing cia and fbi culpability there
were numerous investigations
director radcliffe former dni director
as radcliff has talked about this
i think that's probably one of the
things that they would have had down
there because he ordered those to be
declassified the fact that doj did not
go through with
the process over there for further
dissemination of these documents as
declassified doesn't make those
documents any less so you're you're
talking about the underlying
spy gate documents the original
documents that started the entire
operation that became russiagate that
became the dossier everything else we're
talking about the original
electronic communications and everything
else that was pulled during and this
when you were in uh working with nunes
you worked with cash patel and so many
other and
they like great rich higgins by the way
for example the investigation of what
cia was actually doing
in the evidence that they looked at to
come up with the conclusion that russia
wanted
trump to win in the 2016 election
there's a tremendous documentation there
that shows malfeasance and culpability
they cherry-picked information to get to
a conclusion
and the overwhelming amount of evidence
that pointed in another direction was
put on the cutting room floor
that type of lay down is what director
radcliffe had
it's damning of the central intelligence
agency and of the fbi you know for a
fact that they had that information yes
like you did you see it
i worked on that project
and then so they would have like on a
thumb drive just copies of the emails
and stuff and all that no it was all
it was all
paper copies so but that's weird to me
that they would have like a paper copy
of it and that's it if it burns on fire
you never see it again i mean that's
very inspector gadget
we had it in a vault in in at the cia
headquarters there are other copies so
tremendous amount of work hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours of work
by many people to go through all of the
intelligence that was available to the
central intelligence agency that they
neglected to include
and it was
information that was not consistent with
the narrative that john brennan and
and the director of national
intelligence clapper wanted to portray
to the president
in the fall of 2016 about russia wanting
trump to
i mean russia wanting trump to win
trump did fire everybody
that's a good question we brought in dan
coats to be the director of national
intelligence and you wound up with
the cia director pompeo a lot of this
evidence was provided to director pompeo
in and to the deputy director okay uh
haspel and they decided to do nothing
with that information about
what cia had done to politicize their
intelligence hey derek last time i
checked maybe maybe you can refresh my
memory
who was the station chief so a lot of
this was done in london right right so
who was the cia station chief now any
human operation that's conducted
overseas must be signed off with the
purview and auth really authorization of
the cia station chief for that country
that's how it works so um whoever was
run whoever was working with christopher
steele whatever fbi bruce ohr and nelly
and all this stuff in in the uk had to
be signed off by the london station
chief who was the london station
gina haspel who became the deputy
director of the cia who
also decided not to do anything right
director of cia
so just
how all these people wind up still
popping up
you know peter strzok's wife is leading
the investigation for the securities
exchange commission about the trump
media group wow okay how does lisa
monaco wind up leading the investigation
of trump right now
deep state
it's um i mean it's not even that deep
anymore it's the in your face state yeah
they don't care they just don't care
anymore well i think they they're losing
and i think they they they know they're
losing and i and i'm not saying you know
i have to talk about this this country
destabilizing trump said something
terrible will happen unless we lower
these temperatures uh with
i think all that's true
but i think the reason the temperature
is heating up is because the
bureaucratic state the administrative
state knows they are failing they have
they have lost cohesion and they're
going to be removed very quickly donald
trump was going to fire everybody he's
planning on running and then immediately
you know this the reporting is he's
going to fire everybody once again and
i'd love to see it i'm down for desantis
or anybody else but i'm kind of like
maybe the first thing we do is like you
know let's say you buy buy a new company
you come in you clean house you say okay
this this company's crooked it's corrupt
these employees aren't working but we
got a good base here so we're gonna fire
all these people keep the good ones very
few of them and then we're gonna start
rehiring and rebuilding this thing but
i'd love to see part of why there's
tension is because there's this lack of
vision by leadership in this country
there's no maybe not no plan but like
how often do you see someone in an
established form of government come out
and tell you about their excited plans
for the future
and get people riled up to like yes we
can change the world we can start
terraforming earth like but where's the
real change
proposals from donald i didn't see
pretty much like where is he talking
about fusion for the love of god fusion
power or space trap that's just
something he's talking about space
travel quite a bit a little bit not only
he started space force he started space
wars and he wants to go to mars
he wants a base on the moon to bring us
to mars talking could have done more on
nuclear sure yeah he could have done
more but okay so maybe some people are
or you say something well i was going to
say that you know president trump
looked for new ideas and he wanted to
execute a reinvention of the pentagon
taking a good look at how we do health
care in this country but when you have
four thousand political appointees and
you don't get most your people through
the senate or into the
the lower positions and the ones that
you are getting are people like director
ray the establishment provided him as
this guy's vetted he's good he's
reliable and look what we get when we
get director ray he's part of the rhino
class
there you go when donald when they were
talking about climate change and then i
think donald trump was like i'd never
heard him be like let's fix it it was
more like
uh that's not as big of a problem as
you're making it out to be kind of meant
i don't want to be too hard on don
because he had a big job um but i think
we can fix the climate so like i don't
know man i don't know that's what we
need i think we will de-escalate
tensions when we start producing a myth
a modern myth that we can get behind
just a modern story put a pin on this
that
the people that get me though are the
ones who say oh well trump couldn't
destroy the or you know defeat the
entire establishment in one term i guess
that means he sucks now we should just
stop trying i mean
really if if you actually think you're
up against these all-powerful masters of
the universe who have so much ability
they stole his presidency too great
control all this they took away his what
first three two and a half years just by
two minutes three years two and a half
years and then you get caught into covid
in the last year and then impeached him
and then coveted and even even with all
that we had gas prices were dropping the
economy was booming imagine what he
could have actually accomplished if he
wasn't jammed up with with russiagate
right and that's not cope that's just
that's just what happened okay that's
what happened and if you can't be adult
enough to sit there and look at the
situation
objectively and say yes this was run
against him because trump winning the
white house was a beachhead okay that
was a beachhead that you established but
you're still surrounded in washington dc
by the administrative state and they
came for him they came into the white
house
i remember there was a viral tweet from
one of these lawyers that said we are
going to impeach you
the day like he was getting enough yes
right right from the very beginning so
for my own
my own my own experience
i went in and took over the middle east
effort in the national security council
for the president they went after mike
flynn and took mike flynn out
and mike flynn wanted to execute and
move on the president's agenda for the
middle east he wanted
a new approach for the middle east peace
talks he wanted to move the embassy from
tel aviv to jerusalem he wanted his
first trip overseas to be to saudi
arabia and israel he wanted to get out
of the iran deal
mattis and tillerson
and mcmaster opposed him on all those
initiatives
deep state derek is it true that
mcmaster would
would essentially just just go into him
and and fudge the numbers on syria
withdrawals and everything like that
there was a
in meetings that i participated in there
was a mischaracterization
provided to the president by tillerson
mattis
and mcmaster
i was sitting on this on the the love
seat
behind the view of the the president
could see me and those three were
sitting right in front of the oval
in the oval office in front of the
president trump's desk
and i was right in the line of sight of
of the president and they were telling
them things and i was shaking my head no
and the president would say
my guys are telling me there's another
way of looking at this my guys are
telling me that there's new information
on this did
he would challenge general mattis
they couldn't see me shaking my head
but he picked up on those signals
correctly wow but they were providing
him wrong numbers
mischaracterizing what was actually
going on
and trying to just
[ __ ] him
let's just let's jump to this uh
completely unrelated story for the last
quick segment because we have to
alec baldwin tells the ccp that the
media i'm sorry
the chris cuomo project not the chinese
communist party
that the media is out to get him and
insists he did not pull the trigger on
rust set frustrated actor fumes that the
only question is who put a live bullet
in the in the stunt gun stunt gun as an
actual gun as a single single action
revolver as he away a real gun as he
awaits d a decision on if he'll be
charged charge him
by the way uh jack pointed this out the
chris cuomo project has abbreviated ccp
so chris cuomo's new uh podcast is
called the chris cuomo project aka
ccp and shout out to producer shah at
human events daily who actually noticed
that before me but
his promo code that for for he's got um
he's got a couple advertisers already
his promo code is promo code ccp
okay
we're in a simulation yes
we live in a simulation just i'm i'm
done okay how do we how do we activate
console commands emt i think is the dmf
yeah yeah
dmt yeah
how is it
it
i just i just can't i can't too weird
well there's only 26 letters so there's
one like a 506 one out of 566 000 ccp
well so so here's here's the contention
go to paul mollis.com ccp or whatever
like come on man so the the article
though or the interview um is that so
abc leaked this fbi document which was a
review of the actual occult revolver
that was used on the set it was not a
stunt gun or a prop gun it was just a
gun
and they said
hey this thing can't be fired unless you
pull the trigger
and that's what we were all saying and
that's what everybody said and there's
there's a bunch of things we're still
waiting on but alec baldwin was like i
didn't pull the trigger just went off
and then i i was like he's fanning it
right right right right they pulled the
hammer back and it just went off which
is not possible and so we checked it
right we speculated that no he pulled
the trigger the simple story here it's
very simple alex baldwin on a movie set
pulled out a gun with a live bullet in
it pointed it at a woman pulled the
trigger
and killed her it was a woman that he
was having problems with on set too and
i think he was fantasizing about
shooting her with an empty gun just like
a little kid like bang bang you're dead
and it turned out someone put a bullet
in that gun well there's there was
reporting about the problems he was
having with staff on set
and then this happens what's this
results results are in five percent
five percent in oh hagman 53 liz
cheney44 what source do you have right
now ap first results uh
shoot i'm seeing this uh central valley
politics
central valley politics and i believe
it's from
new york times new york times
oh there we go there we go wyoming at
large
hageman
54
to liz cheney 45 with five four percent
estimated reporting let's get it points
here we go here we go baby why is her
name in that done
so done why does it say hagman braces
for wyoming why are they like
wait what do you mean what are you
getting a hero out of
well why are you is chinese yeah why
isn't it saying brexit they're calling
it this because the incumbent why don't
they she's
wyoming voters choose their
representatives yeah yeah right well
because they've got to run an angle so
the angle is is that liz cheney is their
great avatar and she's being destroyed
by this this you know you know upstart
grassroots mega republican this is
shocking
grey bull with 59
it's a democrat i have no idea who that
is yeah so i'd be interesting to see if
they have uh
details okay so only only a little bit's
in so far i saw the tweet
3486 so far for hagemann liz cheney with
2906
i i almost can't believe it to be honest
and the good news is there's not gonna
be a lot of them the good news is that's
cheney's best district
is it i'm just kidding
no it's it's not large
right yeah at large yeah oh that's right
it's the whole state yes there's there's
one district yeah it's no district but
i'm talking about the precincts that are
reporting oh really yeah shout out to
anthony
so that's casper you and i imagine
cheyenne would probably be her best yep
yup cheyenne is pro
it's already looking good if outside of
cheyenne
huge early lead for hagerman huge
it's like a thou it's like not it's not
even a thousand five hundred five
minutes it's almost a ten point lead so
the votes just closed when do you think
they're tabulating it's coming in now
what do you think like three days until
the total count no well
it's not election day anymore it's now
it's election week and then it's
election months
some time to calculate
we're gonna wait for the mail and
balance to get in yes and count them
next and then 3 a.m rolls around so but
technically it should be done by 2 3 a.m
right isn't that the way these votes
well i still love technically 8 p.m and
they're yeah sooner than that
france france has it done in like five
hours yeah not even the whole country
yeah and 66 million votes something like
that i still love the uh was it the la
county with with the the signatures have
you seen this
that they oh yeah
guess they struck 200 000 signatures
from his petition which just
coincidentally happened to be the put
him right under the threshold for a
recall well so here's the thing
something like 80 or 90 000 were not
registered voters and that should be
very easy to actually verify right so
they they they a bunch were like um not
registered voters or duplicates they
argued the bulk i think were duplicates
and unregistered voters that's like
two-sevenths i mean that's like
20
what percent that's like 38 of the
freaking votes came in where were
nullified if you extrapolate that out
signatures though so this is this is
this is a different thing
you get a petition you walk around you
go hey we're going to sign a petition
they say sure they sign it they fill out
their information
i think 200 000 is a lot it's a lot of
relative votes there were only 760 000
tallied and 200 of them were were not
accepted i mean if you so we call the
united states government if there's a
big election you get 50 150 million
votes these aren't votes these aren't
votes okay there's a difference between
someone going to a polling place being
handed a vote with their name on it
filling it out and then handing it to a
precinct you know captain or whatever
that puts it in the box and certifies it
and someone on the street walking up and
saying sign this so i can understand
that signatures would get disqualified
but i'm saying we can check this one
easily um decision desk is calling it no
what's how yeah
it says right here how long this is
right here
so why so early okay go to decision desk
because they're i would love
love love love to call it right now
um decision desk is calling it
ladies and gentlemen decision desk hq
projects harriet hageman is the winner
of the republican nomination for
wyoming's at large u.s house
congressional district she has defeated
rep liz cheney decision made 9 27 pm
so what's the thug life jack with the
extremism symbol what's the what's the
value of decisions
is decision desk like notoriously
accurate or something it's yeah this is
uh like
typically the most accurate the official
source decision desk comes out and says
it and people usually roll of it this is
the verified decision desk saying it
right there you heard it ladies and
gentlemen
oh yeah you just went to rome
jack just went to the vatican we're
talking about before the shooting yeah i
got a tweet
i got a tweet
tweeting yeah let's go chain you down
cheney down
god is good whenever i see a picture of
her she looks really upset really really
miserable sad like she's frowning looks
unhappy dynasty down yes the end of a
dynasty
too early to celebrate
well i'm just thinking we're talking
about elections and how long it takes
and validating signatures and things
like that and you know we just had a
primary here in maryland and they give
in maryland 10 days for mail-in ballots
to
be received and counted so we had an
election day and they counted the
walk-in early voting because you have
early voting and those get counted in a
batch so you get those results sometime
that evening and then they count people
who voted in person on that day and you
got those late in the day and then you
have to wait for the counts of the
mail-in ballots which
they do two or three days later and then
any balance that come in later they get
counted the following week and then
provisional ballots okay let's just
let's let's just accept that right now
dave lasserman and cook political
reports are confirming our archives
that's great so so you know i get it i
get it but let us let us have this oh
yeah
one minute you know
with five percent and why why so early
or they might have been doing some
polling yeah yeah
exit polls
and and then this there's they may have
access to data that hasn't been
published yet like the ap reporters get
access to stuff they so they probably
have seen
updated just come in and with with with
casper the precinct that they already
have they're probably like yep that's
completely in line with what we have
there's no possibilities cheney's gonna
win if if if she's down 10 right away
i didn't even know who she was that you
said cook politicals also got it
cook political report so dave dave
wasserman and he's he's kind of famous i
mean he's he's kind of a glorified
refresher as richard you've had if you
haven't had richard barras on you got to
get him on i just he's fantastic um i
love rachel i can't believe they called
it so quickly
this guy's a glorified refresher but he
does the whole like i've seen enough you
know right right right he's never seen
those yeah so if decision desk and cook
political are saying it it would be very
insane if they reversed that decision
later on those guys they're they're
generally pretty conservative with this
actually yeah yeah yeah an election
wizard shout out to election wizard he
got called it actually before both of
them he's known for being a little bit
ahead of the grain on this i'd like to
uh give a round of applause to everybody
i think liz cheney is just so awful and
um
democrats should be cheering this right
right right the all the left rachel
maddow everyone who was against iraq
i bet they're all tweeting like this is
the end of america it was funny there
was a tweet from one democrat guy and he
was like if liz cheney loses her primary
it's the end of the republican party and
it's like no one believes you care about
the republican party i want to save it
like if anything everyone assumes the
opposite of what you say is true
liz cheney
you're fired
now we gotta look we gotta look to
alaska
yup yeah that'll be well they're they're
in totally different times right so i
think that'll be a while that's today
yeah alaska's today
now because alaska has a runoff included
in in addition to the rank choice so
they're saying that it's that
if neither get 50
then it goes to the top the top two to
go to a runoff that'll be murkowski and
chewbacca most likely i want to see the
ranked choice tallies if if possible
from the alaska thing because i don't
just want to see what the final answer
was i want to see the process of how it
got to whoever is going to win on that
because i'm really fascinated with
ranked choice voting i think there's a
future it is interesting
andrew kloster liz chaney just collapsed
faster than kabul wow
i mean it's it's i can't believe they
called it i was like we got five percent
we're gonna yeah yeah
it's gonna be three days before they
call it and it was five minutes okay it
was 20 minutes 27 minutes but still
all right we're gonna we're gonna go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcats.com and become a member because
we're gonna have that members only
uncensored show coming up at about 11
p.m and now i am going to source some
super chats from people and of course we
go by the super chats that start at the
beginning of the show so there's gonna
be a lot of people who who at the time
of the super chat didn't realize liz
cheney has lost
all right
jacob tolbert says great show tonight
first super chat does anyone else feel
like order 66 is about to be enacted was
it was that yourself from star wars oh
uh ghost order 66 is about to be enacted
go see larry elder's uncle tom 2 showing
at the hollywood boulevard cinema in
woodridge illinois
august 25th oh very cool sweet that's
when he's like do it and then all the
jedi turn on each other and start
slaying other jedi is that what it is i
don't know this well
well here's the thing though because
liz cheney is now the fourth
uh person who voted fourth republican
who voted for trump's impeachment that
has lost that is now out of that i think
that's at the end of it and how many
resigned
and and yeah
two of them won i'm pretty sure we did
we did a reporting base
you know got in even though she's a fed
and
she's a fed check me on that and she's
definitely lied about that antifa thing
by the way
and one other person won
and there's one more here yeah i can't
remember
raymond g stanley jr says nice first
cast castle vlog i knew irl was scripted
that's right we have the first cast
castle it's episode zero it's just the
promo introduction um the goal is to do
a weekly 22-minute pseudo-vlog sitcom
style show and uh jack's in it
yeah so this was a great bet it rose a
harrowing
journey for me
in this in the lead up to this and we
we're only really catching the end of it
and i'm using my my alarm bell to to
keep everyone at bay while i was able to
actually secure
the scripts for the next season of tim
cast irl from mar-a-lago before the feds
were able to get in there that's what
they were really after i was tipped off
we got them out just be just before the
fbi oh i didn't know you were in there
before that's awesome well i mean you
didn't we didn't we didn't reveal it you
took a lot of wind on the way up here
delivering those too yeah and you're a
little with your little bell on your
bike with your little wagon carrying
scripts for tim cast irl they're they're
if you want to know there was always
talk there was a word field there was a
warp field involved
so you are vibrational vibration
because we just launched the the promo
episode would be like what is he talking
about but if you if you want to
understand what the references is making
check out timcast.comcastcastle
and uh
we're just going to be engaging in
shenanigans and then i will mention too
free damastan is probably going to be um
complete in a couple months the framing
of the new building is going up and the
fredamastan channel is going to be
action sports and and more in that
direction castle's going to be more
silly and fun stuff
all right let's see the almighty truffle
says hey tim i got a pokemon card i'd
like to send you that i think you'd get
a kick out of is it tim pole
uh
kick out of me and the wife were
wondering how can we
i'm not sure anymore we had to stop
taking mail because you know for obvious
reasons but uh there's a pokemon called
timpole
t-i-m i think it's t-y-n-p-o-l
yeah that is though yeah and it's
wearing headphones yeah and a little
beanie thing and it's got similar colors
to our style of colors
yeah it's very weird that's weird
all right actually that that reminds me
um
before i go i don't have it on me right
now but i'll just say it since we're on
air
that uh i got to see president trump a
couple months ago and
um spent a very brief little time with
him but on my way there
there was a and i'm not gonna say
much but there was a secret service
agent who said that he is a
huge fan of tim cass oh sweet and wanted
me to give you a secret service sort of
like a commemorative pin and a challenge
coin oh wow i've got that for you don't
let me forget before i leave amazing i
really appreciate it thanks man i don't
know the guy's name but all right this
is awesome and his wife and his wife
the pippin viking says i've never been
so excited what happened um
the
the the the totals just updated and it's
is it brutal it's br i i've never i've
not actually seen something this brutal
before oh
good let me we we can't pull it up right
now but uh let me pull up on my phone
do you have the numbers you might be
look it's it's a she's up by
20. by 21 hagman's up by 21 right now i
want to read this so early on in the
show before we got the good news the
title of it is liz cheney defeat watch
party the pippin viking says i've never
been so excited for a show title
love the show even if ian frustrates me
sometimes keep up the great work guys
too actually but uh
i have never been so excited for a show
title before the show i was like there's
no big news stories because the biggest
news story really is
right and then jack was like it's the
liz cheney watch party it's delicious
and by the way i love ian on the show
even even when i'm not here i love you
because ian's like the voice of you know
someone who's just not
totally obsessed with politics and news
and you know just wants to understand
and that that i think that you need a
show you need that ownership like the
cross
the crucifix you brought
i think of it as a murder tool
the crucifixion they slaughtered jesus
jack actually did carry the full uh
crucifix up the hill daily
we are going to israel soon it's a
rosary no the no crucifix is that's true
well this is where we by the way do you
know that's where we get the word
excruciating
excruciating comes from the verb to
crucify um cruzio in in latin
and also the cruciatus curse cruciatus
wow that's actually fascinating i don't
think jk rowling probably realized that
maybe he didn't but it's because the
pain of crucifixion
was so horrific that they actually
needed a totally new word bro even
describe it this really changes the
context of harry potter
so you're saying harry potter is
actually catholic no no i'm not saying
harry potter as i'm saying the fact that
one of the curses is the cruciatus curse
which uses that prefix which is rooted
in crucifixion which is and it's
inducing severe pain
it's almost like wow i wonder if all
these lefty harry potter fans are like
no no no sorry
sorry guys they're feeling the the the
the pain and the suffering of the
crucifixion may be like voldemort was
the devil and even even if you look up
actual um
excavations of crucifixions they found
it's it's every single one that they
found that's either been intact or
somewhat preserved
it's it's very or victims of crucifixion
it's almost identical it's virtually
identical to the gospels all right so
it's more david c cronk senior says i
believe kenzinger was gerrymandered out
did you hear that liz was sending out
absentee ballots peter navarro reported
that on war room i don't know about all
that she lost so that's all that matters
and so he just retired i mean you could
always choose to run again yeah well
she's down by 20 points so
i love how they're like four percent
reporting i've seen enough that's good
liz cheney loses
x runner says at least okay i'm like i
can't do it i can't i was gonna read it
i can't do it um
he just said liz cheney will use some
particular app for thirsty establishment
dudes okay man i just it's cool
after victory like this i just don't
know how i'm going to get to sleep
tonight
i just have no idea unless wow did you
see the one about let's just go home
the trainees are a great family just go
hunting with them
county commissioner zinger over here
yeah yeah yeah
all right let's see we got
let's see
what awake not woke says just want to
point out that ian compared his body
odor to ptsd cases
i don't know what to think
it was an intense moment
all right
matt yemen says why are state troopers
in the states with the unaccompanied
miners being flown in not arresting the
flight crew for human trafficking and
seizing the planer to civil asset
forfeiture laws good question
it is a question i would love to hear
answered i mean
and and and charlie kirk has talked
about this that
the only meaningful change that you're
going to have under this regime is if
red state governors actually start
enforcing things sheriff's also by the
way actually start enforcing things like
this
whoa what is this
techroo says in 2016 liz cheney
committed the unforgivable sin of
offering me a coors light
when her hospitality suite should have
been stocked with wyoming beers in 2021
i successfully voted on behalf of my
county for her censure
i think it's funny
like all these people are like liz
cheney has besmirched the good name of
the gop and she gave me a coors life
that's so rude and then that's why she
lost yeah serves her right one guy just
went around like she gives coors light
what's a good wyoming bear does anybody
know i don't know i would love to
get something crafty 16 years sober
wrong guy to ask
did you drink heavily before that no
no i never did the program or any of
that but i just i just gave it up yeah
but shout out to all the friends of bill
out there
goes the dynamite says who wants my copy
of dick cheney's book it's signed
really um burn it just
wow
the number number is going down
it's now 61.35 wow that's why they
called it because they were diseased
this is a blow
she just flew into a political prop
turbine
[Laughter]
i mean
this it's it's a this is the kind of
blowout where
if you didn't okay so her constituency
now will only exist of like i said
before the it's it's the trump true
crime crossover of
your msnbc wine moms and your jake
tapper fans and
these people who just constantly think
if if cable news didn't work didn't
exist and that whole ecosystem didn't
exist liz cheney could not exist past
tonight
wow it's amazing period there's no
constituency for this dapper mcstache
says proud subscriber tim i haven't
heard anyone mention china's housing
bubble an alleged imminent marketing
collapse due to the ponzi scheme scandal
with companies like evergrand are you
following it yeah evergrand is the
layman of china however this because the
ccp already has so much bank ownership
they already own the banks they are the
banks um that they are able to leverage
that and ex you know sort of expand the
bubble while
minimizing the risk and mitigating the
risk as much as they can i want to
dedicate this super chat from kevin
clark to ian
he said in the members only last night
you said we'd have to start flying the
french flag i guess you forgot biden
flew it when he pulled out of
afghanistan ooh
oh brutal
that was a double a double smack yeah
that was a good one
being unprepared of the nazis
yeah that was a good one what was it the
maginot line is that what is the
national line yeah that was and they
were like the germans will never get
through this and they was like over but
they are then they aren't enforced they
didn't build the fences through the
forest because they thought it was
impenetrable but the panzer tanks went
right through it wow i just got a text
from richard barris
good he's so rich he just said he just
said no no it's even worse
he just said the results that we're
getting in right now
this is just the early votes
that
the election dave voting hasn't even
come in yet and that apparently the
casper area has an early vote so that's
the earth
yeah the early vote was going to be good
for her that's probably what navarro was
referring to about the nfd ballots was
these early votes he's saying that the
election day the election day vote has
yet to even come in we could be looking
at a 30 percent blowout i bet it's going
to be worse than that
it's it's not it's not a question of a
gentleman's bet as to whether she wins
or loses it's is it going to be a
30-point spread or is it what's the
spread is the question now and one of
the things i heard on the campaign trail
over the last few months is door-to-door
meeting people the republican voters
are insistent i'm going to go in and
vote on election day i'm going to go in
and vote on i'm not going to do early
voting i'm not going to walk i'm not
going to do mail-in voting
overwhelmingly they were talking about
walking in on election day and i'm going
to be interested in seeing what happens
on the election day voting in wyoming
because it's probably going to be very
conservative focused dedicated
republican voters are going to reject
liz cheney
jason heitman says crowder today on his
show called out disaffected liberals
he said people that say the left left me
are lying because the left has always
been this far left your thoughts on this
tim semper fi incorrect interesting
incorrect crowder i mean look when naomi
wolf is coming out she's been like
what's happening this is crazy but i'll
tell you outright during occupy wall
street we had a contingent of black bloc
leftists that we typically would just
refer to as antifa these days during
occupy wall street you had a small group
of people wearing all black that wanted
to go around and throw bottles they said
respect the diversity of tactics occupy
wall street's core organizational body
assigned security to me as someone who
was like i had filmed people def like
airing out tires from the police i had
outright said i will film you if you
engage in violence and they said we
respect it we believe in free speech
we're gonna make sure these people don't
attack you tim that was 2011.
now
andy no gets brutally beaten and they
cheer for it it used to be very very
different salman rushdie
where's the salman rushdie used to be
a a
hero on the left a hero for freedom of
speech um british indian novelist who
wrote the satanic verses
and he's brutally stabbed uh he's
they're saying he's on a ventilator he
might lose his eye his arms all cut 17
times or something right and insane
right i'm actually surprised that we
haven't seen i mean i'm glad but you
know that there's no video of it that
seems to have come out or at least it's
just the immediate aftermath
and you're not seeing any real response
you know other than a reporting of it
from the last well michaela peterson
mentioned that she was afraid that it
was like
muslim extremist and that she's like
this is one thing i don't even want to
talk about is like criticize islam
because she's fearing for the reprisal
of like religious extremists i mean i'm
kind of about the cartel that is what it
was it was a fatwa that was put out by
the islamic revolutionary government of
iran
um when he wrote this book and ever
since then his life has been on the line
i had did not read this book this is
what's it called again the the satanic
diversity is he talking about the quran
no um i actually looked this up because
i wasn't familiar with it and had and
again this is a work of fiction it is a
work of fiction that he made up
and he is not calling the quran a
satanic verse and that's you know not
i'm not like defending or anything i'm
just saying that that's not what it is
it has to do with these
um
false verses that satan was trying to
insert into the quran
that never got it in it's like a fiction
about verses that never made its way in
or something yeah and then there's a
whole story
involving how they almost got in and
they were taken out et cetera
but the the muslims think like oh he's
insinuating that part of satan's evil is
in the quran
i mean i'm not going to put words in
their mouth but they they issued a fatwa
all right let's read some response to
this gerald armstrong says so tim had
baron trump on his show and didn't know
it we never
[Music]
all right let's see
raymond g stanley jr says what i've
always thought of as once reliable show
break points you mean breaking points
talks negative of maga candidates
jack p-a-o-g what you're thinking about
the pa governor oh i think mastriano all
the way i think i think master is a
fighter um
i think oz is going to lose army colonel
you know oz is
here's my thing for oz okay and somebody
asked me to earlier today they said jack
could you and oz bury the hatchet could
you do something to explain you know why
i should should win or be actually okay
all right the problem is is that he
doesn't come across as genuine
and that's why every time he tweets
there's this this whole cavalcade of
people from the right and the left
dunking on him uh he called a vegite
veggie tray crudite in a recent video
and then so fetterman is out there um
you know campaigning off or fundraising
off of let them eat
and so i thought a funny video of this
could be you know hey maybe it's me and
oz and we're going to get lunch or
something and you do with the video and
he's got to you know just kind of lean
into it a little bit and say
okay so you know just just you know
around here we call it a hoagie all
right this is a hokey it's not a what do
you mean jackets and it's up no no man
around here we call it hoagy why do
y'all call it that let me stop you right
there you don't say y'all you say use
use guys call it a hoagie that's what we
say in philly is use but then you got
the pittsburgh and they say yinz yen's
why do they sit because that's what they
say what about central pa central pa you
call them whatever they want and then at
the very end you got us you know and
then he said something like um
of course working that's like i work on
my tim pool scripts that
you know he would say
you know you'd say well what have i got
to do i got to win i said well well
you know just to be fair
a lot of people have a problem with the
fact they say you're not from pa and you
got to overcome that not from pa what do
you say and then he's sitting there and
maybe he's he he'd
choose a bite of the hoagie or
cheesesteak or if you want to get like
actually i would say okay don't do the
cheesesteak thing because everybody
assumes you're going to do a cheesesteak
don't do that and then say something you
know what it's true
i'm i'm not from here i wasn't born here
i didn't grow up here but and this is
the key part then you say but
but i met a girl from here and i fell in
love with her
and then i fell in love with this state
so he said wagner's
so it's redner's well there's the real
one and then he said wegner's but
there's a wenger's it's well no it's a
wegmans that he's no there's no there is
a oh there's a grocery store in pa it's
probably a single grocery store with the
signs on the wall in the video and it
says wegmans yeah wow and and this by
the way this video and it's from april
it's not recent but
you know it's it's it's not a video
though
it's not live it's not a live video i
mean you could have whoever was staffing
in that day i'm i'm sorry you got to
fire them um just delete that and do
another take and then and then you have
to come across as genuine that's the key
and not only that when he goes this is
joe biden's fault and it ends it's like
bro you got to talk to me you can't just
be like look how expensive these
vegetables are at this wagon this is
this isn't oprah this isn't you know
those old shows you have to you have to
break the fourth wall and you have to
actually show a meaningful connection
with the audience and i'm not saying
that'll work but i'm saying that if you
want to move in the right direction you
have to do that and by the way maybe go
look at doug mastriano because he's a
guy that nobody said could win and then
cleaned up in the governor's primary
david taranto says tim calling 38 grand
a year nothing is amazing i could live
off that my vehicle and house are paid
for though where i live is decently
cheap too i'm not saying 30 year 30
grand a year is nothing i'm saying to
manage a budget of 800 million dollars
in exchange for that amount of money is
like
it's brutal
it's brutal i it's a lot of
responsibility and uh but uh
38k is also low relative to the national
median anyway
and the i think the the average middle
class income but yeah i know a lot of
people make less than that it's it's
good money depending on your job it's
just man i couldn't imagine being put in
charge of such responsibility you'd have
to
really want that job 64 31. resist the
urge
431 6431 like you got a resistance
acting like it's your money because like
if you're doing someone else's if
someone else is doing your finances it's
their finances
if you're not overseeing it
so like that's a big this is why in
singapore that uh lee kuan yew
said that you know so public servants in
singapore actually make
um they make fair market value
and the idea is that he wanted to
compete with your top level
financial jobs or what today would be
like a tech job so he wanted to compete
with that so he actually pays them
enormous salaries because he wants top
talent is it just me or it's not like
pizza it does yeah somebody cooking he's
making pizza or something i know i've
been saying the whole time making me
hungry 25 minutes yeah by the way
where's the food where's the food yeah i
know we should have a tremendous cruise
where's the crudites
where's the crudites
we should have better prepared for the
celebration we really should have vinrie
saltori says nothing to say love the
show and keep it the outstanding work
big super chat really appreciate it
all right
oh i'm going to read it because uh it
deserves to be read chaser says liz
cheney losing has left me speechless
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it's amazing how that that meme is
going to keep getting book sales for
michael knowles forever god bless him
i'm never going to get tired of that but
if i do get tired i'll need the best
night's sleep in the whole wide world
with my pillow.
ghost crusader says 50 bucks says liz
cheney becomes the new female republican
talking head on the view yes that makes
sense i actually think the the best
thing you did was writing by pillow on
the notepad and putting it behind you it
was one of my favorite ones yeah my
pillow buy
pillow just bought buy the pillow and
the horror will end
okay they would go to mypillow.com buy
the pillow okay guys just just just buy
the pillow it's a great pillow it's not
that hard a very good thing this is the
guy that started it by the way it was
how did you get involved how did you
touch your first pillow i guess
you had no idea
all right all right i could go into the
store for the show yeah after the show
after the show
65 31.
34 points
34 is gonna be amazing
closer than i thought it was going to be
closer
who's the 31
who are these those are the crossover
democrats yeah there's the crossovers
yeah
all right jg says um hey everyone i love
the show tim do you think civil war will
prevent hot conflict with china or can
war with china be another unifying event
creating a common enemy like 911
i don't really know man i don't i don't
i don't know to be honest um i think if
there is a global conflict the us will
probably just split world giant is not a
good idea we don't want that no no we
don't want civil war either but a lot of
people thought that covet would unite
the country
yeah no way well it made everybody crazy
so we have that in common
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends big news so
the so what we're doing with cast castle
which is the first episode went up we
got jack basobic in it i believe we may
have some other special guests in it
we are going to be putting together like
a weekly
vlog but it's semi-fictional vlog so
it's like there's going to be real
behind the scenes stuff obviously but
the idea is just to make like a funny
silly vlog with skits like we were doing
back when sheamus was here and then
we're trying to ramp it up it used to be
daily but that's an impossible schedule
and it was just we ran out of money to
operate it so we tried to switch the
model but the first episode is up at
timcast.com and uh you can check that
one out check uh check that show out for
members it's uh it's it's it it's a tour
of the house an introduction all the
people who work here and the things they
do with a bunch of jokes and jack if you
uh like the um
if you want to understand the bit that
he was talking about with his wagon and
coming up here from mar-a-lago i will
not explain not explain it's but we're
gonna we're gonna actually use the
youtube channel we're gonna put
skits on the youtube channel as a way to
just do fun gags with a lot of our
guests we filmed something really
awesome with marjory taylor green which
i'm really excited for check that out at
timecast.com and check out the we're
gonna have the uncensored show coming up
for you at 11. smash the like button
subscribe to the channel you can follow
the show at tim cast irl you can follow
me at tim cast jack do you want to shout
anything out uh yeah we've got the human
events daily show now on real america's
voice every night 10 p.m so we are
uh we we fill that gap by the way
between when this show ends and the
uncensored show starts so when you're
not watching this you go over you watch
human events daily on real america's
voice you ch voice you checked it out we
are powered by turning point usa turning
point usa just announced by the way that
the america fest tickets are on sale
phoenix arizona this december i can't
talk too much
about all of these special guests and
immersive experiences that will go on
there but if you go to tpsa.com and
check it out
where is that going to be do whatever
you want
and where is that jack and i are having
a conversation oh
tim may be on the short list
we'll we'll see if we can figure
something out i don't want to say too
much because i don't like hyping things
up before we've gone through any of the
stuff like to take care of like but
we've got a plan for an epic
oh yeah what was that we went where is
it exactly we got you out there where is
the event phoenix phoenix phoenix and
it's going to be the week before
christmas
oh yeah sounds like a great vacation and
we're expecting um
last year we had i think we had 12 000
last year this year we're looking at 15.
wow yeah all at once sitting in that one
room yeah oh man this is going to be
awesome no no just sitting there going
to be partying partying
sounds good to me
from the ceiling yeah they do it's a
good time to be out there too in phoenix
if you're going to be in phoenix you
might as well go in december you want to
shout anything out derrick no i was
thinking i want arizona state university
i like the state and it'd be a good
getaway for me and my wife
let's do it do it week before christmas
i'm into it
i love the sound of it hey guys great to
see you both always uh
you can follow me did you want to your
social media you said people could
follow you on truth social
derek harvey on truth social or vote
derek harvey dot com and you can follow
me at ian crossland.net get through to
my social medias from there uh much love
i will see you later thank y'all thank
you guys all very much for tuning in
with us as we celebrate the downfall of
anti-trumpism at least the beginning of
it hopefully the start of a red wave you
guys can follow me on twitterminds.com
at sour patch lids as well as sourpatch
lids on me this is just the beginning
yes the midterm
the midterms are coming it's just august
and we're already getting the big good
news we've gotten a bunch of great news
throughout the primaries trump's record
on endorsements is very well despite
sometimes it being dr oz but i'm really
excited for november so it should be fun
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all over at timcast.com
you